fuego avec un appareil qui bouscule la
tradition des chiffres renault la régie
avait choisi l'espagne pour présenter sa
gamme de nouveau coupé deux portes
chargé de faire oublier l'échec des 15
et 17
techniquement la fuego viennent
évidemment traction avant reprend les
bases techniques de la 18 longueurs 4
mètres 36 avec des améliorations
notamment sur le train avant
d'entrée renault propose en france
quatre modèles en combinant diverses
possibilités deux moteurs 7 et 9 chevaux
3 transmission 4 ou 5 vitesses ou
automatique et 2 degrés de finition
mais deux autres coupé à moteur aux
chevaux seront également lancés à
l'automne et nous avons choisi de vous
présenter le haut de gamme c'est à dire
la version la mieux équipée
cumulant toutes les options tout d'abord
un grand coup de chapeau aux stylistes
qui malgré de sévères contraintes
industrielles ont su réaliser une ligne
originale avec cette ceinture et
plaisante tout en obéissant aux
nouvelles exigences de l'aérodynamique
et pourtant la fuego reste très
habitable en largeur aux coudes comme en
longueur et les places arrière malgré de
petits dossiers sont encore très
acceptable
un effort de présentation fonctionnel
caractérise la planche de bord bien
équipé
mais la malle accessible par cette
énorme bulle vitré n'est pas très grande
moins de 300 litres malgré de petits
coffres annexes et de plus les bagages
reste exposé à la vue par contre le
rabattement différencier des sièges
arrière permet cet agrandissement
souhaitable enfin une grande première
chez renault avec un volant réglable en
hauteur mais aussi une servodirection et
des jantes en alliage chaussées de pneus
extra larges très performant
[Musique]
sans qu'il s'agisse d'une désignation
péjorative la série des renault fuego
appartient à la génération des coupés ce
dos sportive étroitement dérivée de
berline de série
ceci pour contenir les prix de revient
immédiatement la clientèle dispose d'un
large choix d'où émergent les qualités
traditionnelles de renault le confort
d'abord mais aussi de faible
consommation notamment avec le moteur
sept chevaux
[Applaudissements]
finalement il ressort du comportement
routier de ces voitures une certaine
homogénéité où les performances pures
s'estompe au profit d'un agrément de
conduite paisible
quant aux prix ils varient de 39 milles
800 francs pour la tl sept chevaux de
base à 49 1800 francs pour la gts neuf
chevaux à boîte automatique
[Musique]